can with one of today's leading
political commentators join us as
in-depth welcomes Lewis Lapham editor
emeritus of Harper's Magazine and editor
of Latins quarterly Lewis Lapham spokes
include the wish for Kings waiting for
the barbarians and gag rule his latest
book is pretensions to Empire Lewis
Lapham it is been almost 20 years since
she wrote in the preface to your book
money in class in America these words
never in the history of the world has so
many people been so rich never in the
history of the world had so many of
those same people felt themselves so
poor has I changed it all in the 20
years since she wrote it I think that
feeling has become more pronounced not
less so I think we still have that
notion that we deserve more I mean I
think you see that in the increasingly
widening disparity between the rich and
the poor in the United States between
also see it in our in our foreign policy
more is the watchword and the sense of
entitlement that passes throughout the
society we being born American we
deserve the best of all possible worlds
and it should be forthcoming over the
next horizon or around the next bend in
the river or with the next election
besides foreign policy that whole issue
of money power entitlement has been a
theme throughout most of your books that
you've written it has been and where
does that come from from you I mean
where did that idea come from that you
wanted to spend so much of your life
writing about these issues well it just
kept coming up I mean it wasn't a
conscious decision but I mean you would
I warned in 1935 and
I'm in San Francisco and I'm in San
Francisco in 1945 when the UN is
established my grandfather was the mayor
who resided over the meetings that were
arriving to UN Charter the United States
had won a great war certainly in Germany
by that time and it clearly was a matter
of time before we were going to defeat
Japan so the sense that Franklin
Roosevelt's Four Freedoms freedom from
one year lead him to worship freedom to
speak and that we had we the United
States had saved the world from great
evil and we're going to advance the
doctrine of human rights put forward by
Eleanor Roosevelt 1948 so there's a
sense of great possibility when Truman
comes to San Francisco in June of 1945
it's the biggest crowd that's ever been
assembled in the history of California
and a sense of bounty in the sense of as
I say a possibility of promise and this
again recurs with the election of Jack
Kennedy in 1960 the young Prince Hal has
acceded to the throne ask not what your
country can do for you what you can do
for your country and so the whole
question of the distribution of wealth
and power and to what purpose what sense
of obligation does the United States
have toward the rest of the world toward
its own citizens so forth and the
distribution of wealth power courses is
the story of politics since time
immemorial I mean this was a question
that the Greeks were addressing in
Athens and certainly the Romans the
ancient it's the question that the
Americans were addressing in the time of
the
the writing the Constitution how to
arrange the system of wealth and power
and so it seems to me it's a great
historical theme and I was just
following it through its manifestation
and they say 40 years between 1960 and
now and in terms of what you said the
relationship with with foreign policy in
2003 in theater of war
you wrote that the fifty years prior to
September 11th the makers of America's
foreign policy over the course of the
previous 50 years had embraced a dream
of power almost as vainglorious is the
one that rallied the disciples of Osama
bin Laden to the banner of jihad yeah I
think there was a similarly grandiose
notion again go back to Kennedy ask I
mean no war too small the expansion of
the American military budget I mean to
the point where we now have 750 military
bases around the world to the
triumphalist spirit that you see prior
to 2001 prior to 9/11 it shows up in the
writings of Charles Krauthammer in
Washington who is saying that we
essentially are wrong we can do anything
we wish and that the shape of the world
is merely a matter of our implacable
will or another variation of the same
theme as Francis Fukuyama in the end of
history we have reached the only
possible solution history as it an end
and from now on it's only a question of
maintenance so yes I mean that that
world encircling vision that we are the
center of the universe Washington is the
center of the universe
and the world should bow to our will
there is something of that same spirit
in any jihadist war quasi-religious view
of Foreign Affairs I mean you would find
the same spirit in the words of Pope
Urban ii when he was rallying the First
Crusade in the 11th century out to
remove the infidel from Jerusalem and
bring the power of heaven to bear on the
misfortunes of the earth I want to go
back to that 1945 period by your
grandfather in San Francisco he was
mayor of San Francisco San Francisco and
someone once called him the infrequently
loved businessman mayor I think he was
conscious they quoted him as being what
was it like to be you to be the grandson
of the mayor well it was very exciting
it was it was my introduction to
politics grandfather had run on a
platform that he would only serve one
term and therefore would call it his
various was he would call the shots as
he saw them which he did I mean and with
the results that the local political
machine got very irritated with him and
tried to have a recall election which he
won by a very handsome majority he was
he was quite popular with the citizens
of San Francisco because he was
extremely accessible I mean he kept us
his home phone was listed he would talk
to anybody that called them to talk to
people in the street and but some of the
entrenched interests got upset with him
but during the course of his morality I
got to
go to campaign rallies or come down to
City Hall to see how the Board of
Supervisors arrived at its position and
also it's during the period of World War
two he's elected 1942 1946 and the so
that when the Navy carriers would come
into the bay sometimes would accompany
the mayor and the launch out to welcome
Admiral Nimitz or Admiral Halsey and the
mayor would be piped aboard and ten year
old grandson would get to come up the
gangway and that of course was very
dramatic and impressive to a boy of ten
to meet the Admiral and the ships would
be clearly having somewhat the worse for
wear of having been in the battles in
the Pacific now some my fine gate ironic
and it's going back a little bit further
in in your family history your your
great-grandfather was the co-founder of
Texaco right I think yeah I think was
one of the three early founders of
Texaco but this one is a great-great
great-grandfather Henry Dearborn was the
Secretary of War in the Jefferson
administration he wasn't my great-great
grandfather he was my
great-grandmother's great-great uncle
Cyril okay my great my great grandmother
was a Dearborn ha and it is her family
and Henry G Dearborn was a well he he it
was a man of some many parts he was from
New Hampshire recruited a 60 soldiers
the militia fought at Bunker Hill and
then he accompanied Benedict Arnold in
the one Arnold doomed attempt to try to
take Maine in the autumn of 1775 and
jury one showed up everywhere in the
Revolutionary War he was at the Battle
of Saratoga
he was at the Battle of Monmouth he was
at Yorktown when Cornwallis surrendered
after the war is briefly on Washington
staff then he becomes a member for
Congress from Maine and then Jefferson
makes him Secretary of War in both
Jefferson administration and after the
war he's made Madison makes him
Collector of Customs of Boston and and
then out of nowhere in 1812 a message
arrived from Madison appointing Dearborn
commander-in-chief the American army in
the East but there was no American army
there there were various militias and
also instructed him to march north and
take Canada which fairly peremptory
instruction he he didn't manage to do
that but he did manage to burn the town
of York which is now Toronto and it was
because of the burning of York that the
British took found that extremely
offensive and therefore burned
Washington in September of 1813 but he
was a very much a career was you know
throughout the whole of the early
American enterprise
how long have you lived in New York
we're actually doing the show from New
York this month I've lived in New York
since 1960 and on 46 years and why so
you left the west coast when I left the
west coast in nineteen the end of 1959
he knew what to come to New York to I
had been a newspaper reporter on the San
Francisco Examiner and I came to New
York in 1960 and began as a newspaper
reporter for the Herald Tribune and then
stayed in New York and went from The
Herald Tribune to The Saturday Evening
Post to Life magazine and then the
personality and so Harper's was what
year that you night - I was a 1971 and
except for a short stint you were there
did until last year yeah I was there
until April 2006
what did Harper's have that kept you
there so long
well Harper's is the oldest continuously
published magazine in America and it has
a wonderful tradition it published
everybody that you've ever heard of in
the history of American letters with he
published Moby Dick
and reported exurban Moby Dick in 1851
and and then it's published Mark Twain
Henry James Norman Mailer Edith Wharton
I mean it's it's a glorious literary
historical tradition yes and so it was
that it was a feeling for the what the
magazine had been and was and still
could become when did you you were gone
from there for just a couple years I was
gone 1981 1983 and that was period of
time in which they let you go yeah I was
dismissed in in 81 and then I was
re-recorded 1983 how did that happen
well that happened through the good
offices of John Oh our otherwise Rick
MacArthur who was a grandson of the John
R MacArthur the big Foundation in
Chicago and he was a and of the magazine
during the late 70s and of my writing
and of the kind of pieces at the
magazine was publishing and when I was
it's a little complicated because in
1980 the magazine up to that point was
owned by the Kohl's family in Minnesota
they folded the magazine in 1980 but it
was rescued before it missed an issue by
the MacArthur Foundation in Chicago
MacArthur Foundation then appointed a
Board of Directors none of whom knew
anything about the magazine business and
as a result I was let go
this alarmed Rick MacArthur who made it
his business to he was then working as a
newspaper reporter in Chicago and he
made it his business to come to New York
get on the board of the magazine and
have me restored
I know Kinsley was in jr. he was he was
there during my absence yeah he was
there very briefly and what is Rick
MacArthur's alliance with Harper's today
he's a publisher and uh as so you know
between us we made a success of it at
would particular with a new design after
1984 financial success well I mean it's
I was never entirely clear on the
numbers but I do know that as of last
year it was at its highest level of
circulation and renewal and news town
newsstand sale so in that end of the
magazine business it is a success you
know people who have never ever picked
up a edition of Harper's still know what
the Harper's index is yeah how did that
happen I don't know it got it got copied
by many different other publications and
forms of it and it also I guess gets
circulated by some sometimes on the
internet or people fax it to one another
it became a a
form that was much copied did you start
it I did and do you recall where the
idea came from
well the idea came during the years the
two years that I was not at harvest
between 1981 and 1983 I was a successful
to hear if across the index range and it
started out I was I was writing and
during those two years I was writing a
column once every two weeks for the
Washington Post and one week I I just
made up an index of it you know it was a
form of a column as a way of trying to
understand the world all of the numbers
in all of the categories were invented
and it was an entertaining cone so that
after I went back to Harper's I took
that idea and turned it into you know
the numbers were real and the categories
were real but but the notion was the
same to give insight into circumstance I
just for if people are not familiar
here's a couple from the January the
percentage of Americans who say they
support universal health care over the
current system is 56 percent the
percentages say they would support it if
it limited their choice of doctors
twenty-eight percent yeah yes go ahead
well I mean it gives you those kinds of
numbers I can remember once we ran a
juxtaposition between the amount of
money that the American government
spends on the National Endowment for the
Humanities and the amount that the US
military spends on the maintenance of
the its various bands and it's the same
number of hundred of million of dollars
average number of times President Bush
used the pronoun I in each of his State
of the Union addresses 36 the average
number of times the President President
Clinton did in his addresses 103 yeah it
gives you a sense of Bill Clinton's
narcissism and there's just some they're
just funny I mean they don't have the
amount a Rhode Island man
I received in a settlement last year
over his faulty penile implant four
hundred thousand dollars the number of
years that he has had an erection ten
just who writes me okay well what we
have is we have we have four interns and
they gather these numbers over a period
of months and it begins by asking a
question or you come across a statistic
somewhere in reading the newspapers or
the internet or magazine and then you
just keep asking questions and you you
build it that way and in other words
it's not passive it's not just letting
it happen at you you have to find and in
often we start with a with a statistic
that will be given to us by the New York
Times or Newsweek and the statistics
often turn out to be wrong the numbers
but they in turn lead to even more
interesting numbers but it's it's a
full-time occupation and then we collect
you live with a computer we have a great
inventory of bank of numbers and then
sometimes you can find a match maybe not
that particular month three months hence
you also started several other portions
of in Harper's they include what they
would include the reading section the
notion of taking found objects in the
form of essays poems that might be have
appeared in a very small publication
like say the Paris Review or Grand
Street for London Review of Books I mean
both domestic and foreign sources then
and we take that and give it a broader
circulation and also take trial
transcript or take police testimony or
take letters written to government
officials or between citizens and and it
was a intersections called readings and
it runs to about between say sixteen and
twenty pages and you can do wonderful
things with it because there is a lot
written there's a lot said that doesn't
find a very large audience and you just
lay it out there
just lay it out there but again it works
with the same principle of juxtaposition
or theme and variation so you can put
various things together and then the two
things together add to a sum greater
than their parts where did you learn to
write I learned to write at I guess
first grammar school and then prep
school I had both a grammar school in
San Francisco and at a prep school in
Connecticut I had teachers who were
extremely strict on points of grammar
and so I had to learn to diagram
sentences the old classic diagramming
sentences yeah and also by reading and I
had one teacher in grammar school who
once a week would take me downtown on a
streetcar to buy a a new book I mean if
I done well in my weeks work the prize
was I got to go downtown and and he find
some book for me to read and so it's by
reading that you you learn to write as
far as I know that's the the only way to
do it you wrote recently or that you
thought your writing was getting better
because you were using less adjectives
did I yes that's true I mean it's
getting a little simpler I mean if I
read something that if I read back on
essays I wrote 20 years ago I can see a
lot of unnecessary words and I can see
where I make a mistake of
I'm choosing the the rhythm of the
language or the sound of the word over
the meaning of the word of the structure
of the sentence michael kinsley said
this about your writing style he said
that one of the mysteries of Lewis
Lapham is what the hell is he saying
when he's writing I sometimes feel like
I'm in a reading comprehension test and
I'll turn the page and there'll be the
question like what's the theme of this
passage well I think that's with all due
respect I think that's Kinsley's problem
more than my problem the the over time
over the last say 30 years the kind of
reading comprehension level of the
generally speaking in the US has gone
down I mean if you I read when I read
back in the history of Harper's Magazine
in the in in the year 2000 we did a 150
year anthology and in order to put
pieces into that collection I I was
reading the magazine in the 1850s 1920's
1930's and so on and you can see up
until the first up until a second war
the vocabulary that the writers have who
are writing for the magazine is enormous
compared to to what it is today this is
a world before television they and they
they use these they use language not to
be pretentious it but there's an
abundance of it I mean they have it's
almost as if vocabulary and literary
structure or endangered species I read a
statistic somewhere
that in 1940 the average vocabulary of a
American high school senior was
something like 12,000 words and today
it's 6 an answer is you can at that of
that tendency of course is exacerbated
by television I've written for
television as well as for print and it's
a completely different medium because
with television it has to be it's like
writing Dick and Jane I mean it has to
be a subject verb object and you can't
back into sentences with complicated
clauses and and the tones of the various
tones of irony get lost on television
because it's not of course on c-span but
be but on most television you don't have
time for that kind of construction and
people are interested in data and the
our journalism of which Kinsley is a you
know he's a very bright guy but the
language of our journalism has become
increasingly focused on on data you know
information and not on style or not on
the subtlety of language first I want to
tell our viewers that we're going to
open up our phone lines and invite you
to join us Lewis Lapham is this month's
guest on in depth we have three
telephone lines he'll be with us for
about two and a half hours more and for
Democrats if you would like to join us -
OH - 737 triple zero one for Republicans
- OH - seven three seven triple zero -
and for independents two oh two six two
eight zero two zero five we our lives
this month in New York City we do not
have access to bring you email questions
so if you would like to
and talk to mr. Lapham use the telephone
this time okay so I want to with that
premise on your writing read to our
viewers something that you wrote
recently in your notebook section just
to give people a feel for you so what
you wrote and then you can make any
mention one turn you wrote this
democracy is born in dirt nourished by
the digging up and turning over as much
of it as can be brought within reach of
a television camera or subpoena we can't
lay out a new agenda for America unless
we know which America we're talking
about the one that embodies the freedoms
of a sovereign people or the one made to
fit the requirements of a totalitarian
state we owe it to ourselves to know the
difference seldom in our history have we
been offered a better chance to learn a
more useful civics lesson and by holding
up to the light the malfeasance non
seasons and all other rot embedded in
the character and conduct of the Bush
administration we might discover what we
mean by America the Beautiful like it or
not and no matter how unpleasant or in
politic the proceedings the spirit of
the law doesn't allow the luxury of
sidious silence or discreet absent ism
that's not bad I would say that was so I
think I was writing that are going for
the impeachment proceeding brought to
bear on President Bush and Vice
President Cheney when did you first
decide that you thought that the
president vice president should be
impeached
well I I think about two years ago there
was a report by Michigan Senator John
Conyers who was and it was brought in I
believe December of 2006 going through
telling the whole story of the Bush
administration
setting up the war in Iraq on a false
premise Inanna and what they knew to be
a false premise
and that this was sufficient reason for
impeachment it was a great deal of other
detail but that was the essential point
in other words that the Iraq war was the
perpetration of a criminal fraud on the
American people which I'm sorry I mean
congressman Congress Conyers right yes
yeah an attorney yeah
chairman of G check me yeah why'd I say
senator I'm sorry I think I think you
did I meant two congressmen and so I
read the report and I had also from the
beginning it was the Iraq adventure I
had you know long before we got to March
of 2003 I had been writing pieces in
Harper's Magazine suggesting that the
our response to the 9/11 was exaggerated
and there and what the whole notion of a
war on terror was a war on an unknown
enemy in an abstract noun and he used
the word war was a serious mistake so it
was coming out of that and coming out of
the the way that the Bush administration
promoted the war with the aid and
assistance I must say of most of the
American news media so I was conversant
with quite a few of the points that
Conyers was making and also by this time
books were beginning to come out
I think Richard Clarke had written his
book and I think secretary O'Neil had
written his book and I think Bob
Woodward even had written his third
summation of the Bush administration
each time changing the tone but I mean
it and in the third one I think he was
beginning to smell a wrap
so I was not alone in it by December
2006 in this impression this was your
most recent book which was really a lot
of a good grouping of your essays on a
lot of this issue and to show our
viewers this said the cover of this boy
yeah
what does it mean what was a cover made
that was the inside you will find that
that's an eagle right then inside and
among the epigraphs at the beginning you
will find a song composed by former
secretary the former attorney general
Ashcroft let the eagle soar yeah like
she's never sword before from the rocky
coast to Golden shore but the mighty
eagle soar soar with healing in her
wings as the land beneath her sings only
God no other Kings right but then you
have to read the other idea of an eagle
ah Benjamin Franklin we have underneath
it for my own part I wish the bald eagle
had not been chosen the representative
of our country he does not let his
living he does not get his living
honestly he is never a good case but
like those among men who live by
scharping and robbing is generally poor
and often very lousy besides he's a
ranked coward yeah so there are two
there are two theories of the eagle and
the one of the themes in all of my
writing for the last let's say 30 years
is the argument between the American
democracy on the one hand and the
American nation state on the other hand
and the Eagle is the emblem and
representative of the American nation
state not of the American democracy and
so the American people had no quarrel
with Iraq
the American it for the purposes in the
American nation-state war in Iraq seemed
to be a good idea just as the war that
was declared on in Vietnam in the war
that was the spanish-american war so but
that's a theme that runs all the way
through not only my own writing of the
last thirty years but all the way
through American history I mean it's the
same theme that comes up with both
Lincoln and soro when they will have
nothing to do with the Mexican War it's
the theme that is very much present in
the writing of Mark Twain at the turn of
the 20th century and the
anti-imperialist league so you asked
earlier about them you know distribution
of wealth and power and really this is
the theme the American democracy the
American Republic the American people on
the one hand the American nation state
sometimes called the American Empire
sometimes called the inside the beltway
crowd sometimes called special interests
I mean they've been various their
various ways of just American oligarchy
as opposed to the American democracy
that but that's the argument and runs
through through our history and and and
through the last it's the argument
that's will be the underlying theme of
the next elections as does anybody ever
say to you why are you writing about
class and money when you went to prep
school
you're your ancestor was one of the
founders of Texaco you certainly aren't
one who is in need of cash you certainly
run with a crowd that is one might say
is of the elite yeah but that seems to
me that the best critics of the elite
are
people who are themselves sufficiently
well-acquainted with your lead to see
its faults and that's the point the
point is not to again this is the
argument that that you can see with the
writing of the Constitution you can see
the same argument in the first or the
gather 1st century BC in Rome where
Cicero is talking about placing his
hopes on a ruling class or what we would
call an establishment that has some
sense of moral force and does not become
rancid and corrupt elites tend to become
over time so vainglorious and
self-preoccupied that they lead the
nation into big trouble and the I mean
the to criticize the elite is simply to
to criticize that whatever happens at
any particular point in time to be the
ruling governing possessing class and
all societies have a ruling governing
and processing class it's just a
question of how is that class made I
mean in up until he would in France
under the Kings or in England under
George the 3rd that class was formed at
Birth by inheritance and based on land
extraordinary sense of privilege this is
one of the things that in wage the
Americans when in
in the 17:70 we don't have a system at
least we haven't had as much of a system
maybe we're getting toward that system
of it not based on inheritance it's it's
it's a more open what we hope to be a
meritocracy to let you still in the end
that what you are making is the is the
ruling in the governing class that's
what
when Yale University is established in
1701 it's the purpose the announced
purpose is to produce clergymen and
magistrates capable of governing both in
temporal and spiritual affairs the
colonies and Yale still prides itself on
that intention you ask anybody at Yale
what is the point of a Yale education
what is he'll doing and they say to
produce leaders and so while other
universities and Yale is happens to like
to make that announcement the but that
is the point of Harvard and Princeton
and many of our universities and also
that is not to see Ivy League I mean
it's we manufacture our ruling class in
DNA in the same way we manufacture 747
so and that's that's our great strength
here did you graduate from you 1956 they
don't read somewhere in one of your
books you wrote that yet the class and
plus ranking and Yale used to be in oh
boy well see how they live well it
wasn't by what grades you got no not for
the first hundred years not through the
18th century you were ranked according
to the how rich your father was and so
the
one student in school was the richest
invincible but the that's the way the
social balls worked in Philadelphia
prior the American Revolution I mean a
British officer would be in Philadelphia
and wonderful when Pennsylvania was to
laconic colony I mean a British officer
nor mystic rat was a important celebrity
in the same way that Prince Charles
would be an important celebrity today if
he was somebody was giving a charity
ball in his honor at the Metropolitan
Museum and the way the dance cards were
arranged the girls who got to dance with
the visiting officer were ranked
according to their wealth the richest
girl dance first and so on but that's I
mean money is our great I mean that is
what gives one the chance to rise or
fall in the world in the u.s. it's not
it's not birth oh it's Lapham our guest
on in depth let's take some of your
phone calls
first up in Chicago hello I thank you
haven't we had wars on drugs since the
Fourth Crusade as a spice or and then
the Iran slave trade the Boston Tea
Party the Whiskey Rebellion the opium
wars alcohol prohibition and I'm sorry
I'm gonna I'm going to let you go on
that let's go next to or vana Illinois
hello taking my call unless they're like
if you could question how to do it
really quickly like that which I was
wondering uh Mitchell Adam like if you
just like explain like the Lapham
quarterly like watch the the target
readership in like who what kind of
people are going to write for it then
like I saw that you wrote a blurb for
like a peter king or a book the last
days the run is on
I'll just wearing if you could say like
like what's your connection with having
like how you are approached to give the
blurb and then also a stigma is that
that's that's that's true thank you
first Lapham quarterly Latin quarterly
is is a new journal quarterly journal it
will appear position on October of this
year and it's the quickest way to
describe it is the great books made
topical it will be roughly two hundred
and twenty-six pages it will begin with
a theme and is in the news first issue
with states of war the second one will
address the problem of ruling and
possessing class the third one will
probably to address the idea of God put
and then the fourth one the idea of
money and so I will write a brief
introduction and then run out a series
of texts beginning with the Greeks Homer
or acidities and bring to bear those
texts on the frame of the present and
that will be the bulk of the quarterly
and in the back there will be essays
from contemporary historians dealing
with the same or similar theory or
similar themes or just talking about the
uses and misuses of history I I happen
to believe that the historical
consciousness has gone missing from
broad sectors of both the private and
public sectors in the American mind and
that as was pointed out by Cicero not to
know what happened before one was born
is is always to be a child so that the
sense of the historical context is what
I think gives meaning to the present and
also makes possible
the construction of the future
first edition comes out when October and
how do people subscribe well with the
direct mail some of the direct mail
dropped as they say in the business last
week I also have a website balance
quarterly dot org and it could people
can subscribe through the website what's
it going to cost it's going to cost $60
a year you're you tisha will be about 50
but I mean to me that's a fair price
because the each issue is the equivalent
of a very high quality paper bag and you
had an interest in being storing
yourself at one point I did I guess I'm
a historian monkey I started I graduated
from Yale in 1956 and then went for a
year to Cambridge University in England
with the thought of becoming an
historian and I had discovered that I
didn't have the patience or the
temperament of a scholar also I was
loath at that point in my life to learn
medieval German so I spent a year in
Cambridge and then came back to the
United States and went to work as a
journalist in San Francisco second part
of that was color was about writing a
blurb for a book did you I don't know
I gave write blurbs for a book
occasionally I do yeah when I when I
know the writer or a knight or when I
think the book is good and I don't know
which I couldn't understand about
Renaissance vision hang on
I don't know what which book is talking
about it if he's talking so but it would
be the case of having read the book and
not everybody who writes blurbs reads
the book what I do
next is Queens New York hello oh hello
mr. Lapham it's an honor you know I hope
I get enough time here first thank you
for your long decades of what I consider
a service to the readers of Harper's
Magazine including myself to get up as
both a writer and as editor I think it's
been great and I was sorry to see you go
last year but at least you're still
doing the bimonthly column so a question
okay the question was that in your long
experience that I wanted to tap actually
into that historical sense of yours
having especially in what you've
witnessed since World War two about the
development of secrecy in power the
secret state the CIA the NSA the degree
to which all this was more private or
less private back back when you first
became aware of it the degree to which
it has been privatized into networks of
influence you know is there still a CIA
or is there just the network of
connections behind it and also if you're
willing to take a position on the
various ideas about September 11th as
having come out of that area of secret
power the degree to which some up in
Laden perhaps is the function of
American foreign policy and 9/11 itself
may have been an orchestrated event not
these theories about demolitions but in
the larger sense of orchestration range
thank you clapping well there's certain
to answer the questions in turn
certainly there has been since World War
two when since the setting up of the I
forget the exact name of the act but
it's the act that sets up a national
security
apparatus in 1948 Porter which is a CIA
and but many other intelligence agencies
intelligence gathering agencies within
the United States government I mean I
wouldn't be able to tell you exactly how
many there are but they're more than we
suppose
and yes the classification of
information has become increasingly
severe off-limits to the American public
and that's been a steady progression
over the last 50 years there there there
are far more secret documents secret
correspondences secret theta of all
kinds now than there were say 50 years
ago and in this of course is further
compounded when you have Bush putting
presidential papers off-limits or Henry
Kissinger making a deal with the Library
of Congress that nothing of his will be
read in for another 30 or 40 years and
so the ability of people in power to
sequester their their own records all of
that has is moving in the same direction
so it is increasingly difficult for the
ordinary citizen and even for the
members of Congress to find out what is
true and what is not true or who are our
friends and and who are our enemies I
mean prior to the Democrats winning
control of both the house in the Senate
last year the Bush administration was
utterly unresponsive to requests from
committees of both the House and the
Congress for information and as to the
waging of the war in Iraq or the
distribution of the spoils to various
American contractors and so on so yes
our government is becoming increasingly
privatized and government information
that should be available to the general
public not available to general public
as to the question of what happened at
in 9/11 I am reading at the moment a
book by a man named David Griffin on the
debunking of the 9/11 debunking and he
raises a number of sharp questions I am
not yet which I think deserve further
questioning and investigation but I am
not as yet prepared to sink that's the
bringing down over the 9/11 I'm sorry of
the trade kind of Towers was the work of
the Bush administration Royal Oak
Michigan go ahead thank you for taking
my call mr. Allen I wonder are you aware
of the reports that the Mohamed
ElBaradei made to the Security Council
on the very day before Bush give this
2003 State of the Union speech in which
he used an IED regulation connection
Mohamed Adel how do you reported on that
day that is a bad grade he had yet to
find any evidence that Saddam had
revived this nuclear weapons program
that was discontinued in the early 1990
and another question is that since that
January 27 was the day that the Bush
administration one of the UN inspectors
the report of the Security Council that
Jonathan
I assumed was present and then asked you
to comment on how he could sit behind
Colin Powell by he on February 5th 2003
when he was asserting that these tubes
were to be used for making nuclear
weapons and our thanks thanks Michigan
well I mean I'm not aware of the precise
conversation that you mentioned but I am
aware that the Bush administration knew
that the evidence that it was putting
forward to justify the invasion of Iraq
was false I mean the certainly Powell
knew that he was not telling the truth
on the everybody knew there was no
connection between Hussein and al-qaeda
I can remember having a conversation in
the winter of 2003 with Hans Blix who
was the in charge of the UN weapons
inspection and was clear to him that the
any nuclear ambition on the part of
Hussein had been abandoned for quite a
few years so it's clear on the record
that the Bush administration was
operating on on false premises that they
knew to be false premises without fear
hi I'm going about hello
you had your answer good I calling about
the question regarding the 20 October
2002 agreement from the Congress to give
the president the authority to go to war
is necessary and the role of resolutions
are written in the UN which allowed
which it almost was a visitation the
United States to do something about
Saddam Hussein doesn't agree
that sodomist feelings flowing was a
good that effective yes that was part of
the sales pitch on on the part of the
Bush administration and it was sold to
the Congress in October of 2002 there
were some notable exceptions a speech
made by senator Byrd from West Virginia
in which he you know he actually says to
the his fellow members of the Senate
five fie on on you for granting the
president these kind of powers on the
basis of practically no with no
justification at all but most of the
members of the Congress for whatever
reasons accepted the sales presentation
put on by the Bush administration and
part of that sales presentation was the
connection to al Qaeda X is Springfield
Illinois hi hi I'm very happy to talk to
you mr. Lathem I've followed you for the
last 20 years and I think you're well at
least number on the greatest writers of
your generation I have two quick
questions for you a lot actually maybe
it'll be quick the first one is do you
consider yourself a journalist verse
being an intellectual and the second
question hat a question has to do with
class I just finished reading a book
called the global class war by Jeff Howe
and in that book he postulates that the
middle class upper middle class and
blue-collar workers are facing ultimate
demise because of the interaction and
between these global elites of the very
wealthy extreme wealthy the extremely
powerful of corporations and their
leaders and a very powerful politicians
I'd like for you to comment on that
postulate thanks Springfield answer the
first question I consider myself an
essayist more than a journalist or an
intellectual I would simply say I was I
was in essayist
and an amateur historian the answer the
second question certainly the evidence
suggests at least in the United States
is that the middle class is is beginning
to dwindle and that we are dividing
ourselves too I expect to be our
eventual sorrow between the rich and the
poor
neither the rich and the poor have much
interest in in a working government the
rich can take care of themselves and
hire their own security forces and their
own air transportation and their own
information networks and their own
residential enclaves so that they don't
necessarily have much interest in for
the infrastructure
the Commonwealth the common
infrastructure which is on which the
national enterprise is based and the
poor are usually in such pushed so hard
against the wall or day-to-day existence
that they don't have time to work at the
mechanics of the government and I think
I think you probably I don't I would be
very interested to read the book but the
you see what happens when the middle
class of vanishes this happened in Rome
it got to a point where the the
Republican magistrates the people who
had ministered the Republic and then
continued to do so during the first
century the Empire these people begin to
disappear on the running of the military
is no longer in the hands of the
citizens it's been
outsourced to Gauls vandals Syrians
Egyptians and so forth
and the same thing begins to happen to
what were the Roman public services if
you lose a middle-class you lose it you
lose democratic government 2001 you came
out with this book a lights camera
democracy and I ask you that because you
mentioned earlier Bob Woodward and you
wrote and about him in this book you
said this as with politicians and oil
company lobbyists access is all and no
journalists in Washington over the last
20 years has played the courtiers part
more gracefully than Bob Woodward a
managing editor of The Washington Post
the famous author of many books the
model of the heroic journalist played in
the movies by Robert Redford Woodward's
work and reputation rest on his gift for
ingratiating himself with anybody in
officer power with whom he can trade the
favors of secrets kept and rumors
revealed his celebrity as an
investigative journalist ie the tireless
champion of Liberty pacing ferociously
to and fro on the ramparts of freedom is
one of the better jokes of American
journalism I think that's true I mean I
think Woodward is an extremely
accomplished panegyrists
or what would be a court here I mean
he's a man who knows how to play how to
find his way to the year of power and to
the channel that into a dramatic copy I
mean I could be wrong about this but at
the best of my knowledge and
recollection in the All the President's
Men book there is no named source and
the
and then I think of the various Woodward
books whether it's the one about Casey
as the CIA or the one about Powell when
he was the commander in chief or the
Secretary of State I can't remember when
it came but or the one about the Supreme
Court in other words it's always coming
from from an interested source that
Woodward manages to promote and I think
he's written three books on the Bush
administration the first one is bush's a
hero and as you know takes us orders
directly from god and aren't we lucky
that we live with such a great man I
mean essentially that's the tone of the
first one second one is beginning to
have some doubt and I believe the third
one is now taking the position that
these people have made a mess but by
that time the the shift of opinion has
taken place I mean Woodward is a man
that has his you know he's a weather
vane from which way the wind is blowing
he's very good at it but the and it's a
kind of journalism but it is a
journalism that is totally dependent on
sources sometimes anonymous I'm not a
Michigan high you're on with Lewis
Lapham good morning I mean kids
afternoon can you hear me okay yeah
hello yes I could make mr. Latham I've
been reading you for a number of years I
am I'm of the age I came back I'm a
carrier from World War two I was called
back into Korea so I won't get into the
worst thing there was a yesterday book
notes have on a speaker for the Heritage
Foundation what he said was in essence
was he was in favor of Bush's
pre-emptive war and then he will go down
as a great president which I don't agree
with and the other thing I want to
just talking about it Brian had against
on the other day in the best one of the
best things I've heard a long time Randy
Rhoads
we will never have a representative the
government unless we stop this campaign
huge money we have to have campaign
finance reform which I agree with IRA
what got me it just I've been following
you for years I first read wish for
Kings and correct me if I'm wrong I
believe right now Jim Baker was the
Secretary of Treasury for Regan at the
time of the bank scandal and guess is
right yeah okay he resigned he left
there he went to Texas with a bob Moss
Baker and himself they were pushed to
set up the election of Bush 41 that's
where the big money started the hundred
thousand dollar contributions the
Rangers and big-money hit big time and
then 41 was elected with the help of
Ailes and ant water and the Willie
Horton thing George Burns like can I'm
sorry can you kind of wrap that up in a
question for mr. Lapham I'm going to say
quickly we have Bush numbers right there
for the 491 war and a baker resigned the
state again he went over the White House
with moss Baker again and I'm sorry
thank you very much for your call but
we're going to keep moving on if you
don't have a question Smithtown New York
hello Graham Vanunu it's a pleasure to
talk with you folks I'm really enjoying
this interview I have a question mr.
Lapham
you obviously are well-educated and have
it breadth and depth of experience and I
was curious you had brought up topics on
say the Greeks and the Romans you
mentioned vocabulary and writing
sentences do you have a list of books
that you would consider required reading
for somebody and if so is that something
that you had planned
or could plan on using your quarterly
Lapham's quarterly for yes I mean I do I
mean I'm constantly suggesting books to
people and it's by no means
comprehensive it just happened to be
books that I'm particularly fond of or
attracted to I mean one of them would be
I yes if you send if you get hold of me
at the quarterly I can I can give you a
list also our viewers you have given a
list of us we will be showing to our
viewers or during an upcoming break
includes Edith Wharton Herman Melville
let's see all right we're eager oh yeah
Denis Diderot latter bernetta cough
Robert Ekman when you look what is it
about these people that have the
synthesised for you
something that makes your favorite book
is it the writing is it the topic what
is it it's it's it's the writing all of
these people are people who have a
distinctive voice and style and rise
above the simply the data base I mean
they write with I think force and grace
and I and that is what gives meaning to
their work
you wrote someplace that when you pick
up a piece to read you give it three
pages and if you can't if you can't hear
a voice in three pages that's it that's
it woof if I don't hear a voice and I'm
not quarreling with with what kind of a
voice I'm not I'm not quarreling with
the politics it's not an ideological
decision but it's a question of is this
writer writing out of his or her own
thought feeling experience observation
is he or she trying to
get out of truth of one kind rather
there are obviously infinite numbers of
truths as there are infinite numbers of
stories but what gives it coherence and
meaning is is by being able to hear and
writing to me is more a matter of the
year than it is in the eye that that
voice of somebody struggling to get to
the the truth so as you're reading this
are you reading it aloud no but I'm
hearing it a lot you're hearing it a lot
job next we have a call from
winston-salem North Carolina hi yeah I'd
like to ask mr. Lapham a question please
of all in 1970-71 I just gotten out of
college and I went to Washington to work
in the civil service area and I was
involved for a good while there and what
we will call the White House complex
executive office building new executive
office building that type of thing and
it's just a neophyte so to speak I
observe that egotism plays a big role in
politics a lot of times and later later
I came to find out that maybe some of
this resulted in what we'll call
Watergate so to speak when I came back
to go to graduate school and Watergate
broke and all that I might ask you you
think egotism played a role in the Iraqi
situation is forest but we literally
between the Bush family and the Saddam
Hussein family and you know with Saddam
being in power from the first Iraqi war
to the second Iraqi war and you would
see him on television every once in a
while smoking his big cigar and waving
his sword and shooting the rifle in the
air and all that wasn't ending an
embarrassment to the Bush family
and I seen the administration mr. Cheney
house so to speak and have you ever
heard anything
thanks for telling we'll leave it at
that clapping well I would say that
egotism and vanity has is always a
prominent part of any political story
the desire for men to rule over other
men is you find that from the very
beginning of written records and I don't
think one would go into politics without
a strong sense of one's own ego and
hoping to find in the applause of the
public for the votes of the electorate
some a mirror in which the politician
can see reflected the proof of his or
her own glory
I think ambition is and the wish for
fame renowned celebrity however you want
to whatever we're doing choose to use is
is always present you know in all
politics I mean this clearly moves
Napoleon as it moved Julius Caesar as it
moved
Adolf Hitler as it moves George W Bush X
Washington DC good day how are you all
I'd like to give to Harper's index and
Reid principle six of the number of
principles if I may one is the limiting
age projects it is 10 billion dollars
per year to stop AIDS in Africa and we
spent four hundred billion dollars
committing genocide in Iraq killing at
least a million people this time James
Baker spent 100 billion dollars in 1991
Secretary of State buying the UN vote
that's from Washington Post article it's
very clearly defined last as principle
six of Nuremberg principles written
work to veterans the crimes hereinafter
said it's punishable crimes under
international law crimes against peace
planning preparation initiation war of
aggression in violation of international
treaties agreements and assurances to
participate in a common plan or
conspiracy for the accomplishes venting
the acts mentioned under one to war
crimes violation law the customs will
Warwick include but not limited to
murder treatment of deportation of slave
labor arrived it purple hell puss out
here help us out here what are you
trying to tell us
Nuremberg principles number six why
portation
why color because we are either this law
man and I think it ought to be published
or gotten out to the public and use we
be finished by now that's how short it
is okay thank you for that we'll go next
to Mount Prospect Illinois hello good
morning good morning I'm honored to be
able to speak with you I have a somewhat
lighter question included in your list
of books is a discussion about the
Beatles and I was curious if you could
reflect about the time that you were in
India and why you wrote this book so
many years later on and just a little
bit about your experience there thank
you in 1968 I was a contributing writer
to the Saturday Evening Post and the Zen
editor Otto Friedrich sent me to
Rishikesh in India to spend two or three
weeks with the Beatles who were then the
greatest celebrities in the Western
world and their every movement was a
matter of extreme interest to many
prospective readers of The Saturday
Evening Post
add the there they were on an ashram
above the Ganges River in the foothills
of the Himalayan mountains with a guru
by the name of the Maharaj sorry the
Maharishi Mahesh Yogi and
they were there for a spiritual retreat
and I managed to introduce myself
gradually up the hill the same ashram
and spent two weeks with about sixty
other people of whom the Beatles were
clearly the most important and so I got
to know them slightly I didn't press
them for interviews or for their
thoughts on the meaning of life but I
would be sitting at the same table or
attending the same meeting with one or
another of the teachers of what was then
called Transcendental Meditation and
there would be you know it was it was
very beautiful it was overlooking the
river it was there were the lodgings
were rural did you learn how to meditate
I learned how to meditate there were I
had there were many monkeys in the trees
and I had a pet monkey that would follow
me around because I would take care to
feed him generously and I learned
something about Indian philosophy
something about music his Indian
philosophy has something to teach us
yes it does and the I'd studied it to
some degree at college and I'm not yes
it I would think it would and do you
meditate today No next is Larchmont New
York hello well I had originally tuned
in at the time when mr. Lathem was
discussing Bush's impeachable offenses I
thought that I was the only one in
America that thought that there had been
an impeachable offenses which for some
time I was listing but it was to
aerating to go on and that you know
I have is there anyone else out I am
horrified that I am not literate enough
to be to know you to have read you but
in terms of groups of people and
organizations in whatever to pursue this
I am appalled and amazed about the kinds
of things that have gone on that I I
have found to be the most incredible
high crimes and misdemeanors and I take
this seriously
I was well trained in school in civics
and I held office locally for three
terms and my oath of office was the same
as his I couldn't have done those things
but this is basically I'm spitting it
out as best as I can because while you
wait you're talking about other things
so Larchmont thanks very much if you
will had a reader who wanted to read
about your feelings on impeachment of
Bush would these be the two books
certainly yes those new books but there
are also many other people I have by no
means alone I mean there is the
congressman john conyers report there
have been as a book written by men and I
think John Nichol there there you can go
to the move on.org website and find a
number of motions to impeach and there
are a lot of people who have had the
same thoughts as that caller and the
they haven't been much noticed in the
mainstream press but they there is a
large body of feeling on that topic in
the review of theater of war one of the
reviews that was written by Peter
Preston of the Guardian weekly the
British organ British Journal they wrote
this is Lapham and adornment to American
journalism absolutely is his critique of
wars not worth fighting perceptive and
exhilarating often better than that why
then do he and his fellow sages sit on
the periphery
under any administration democrat or
republican because in part they choose
to because the sidelines fit their sense
of rectitude and superior self better
it's a terrible shame how do you respond
to that criticism I mean I don't
understand what the man is saying I mean
the the the the observer the writer the
essayist is by definition on the
sidelines I mean I'm not a a politician
I mean I presumably he is wishing that I
were running for office but it is that
it is the role of the the essayist and
the writer to to write and to do so in
public to do so in a magazine or on
television or on the radio is is a very
civic gesture I mean so I I think I
really don't understand what that what
he's after
base Arizona you're next Miss Arizona
Thanks go ahead I have three very short
but related questions that I'd like to
ask first mr. Lapham what do you see is
the cultural implications of the Iraq
adventure for the Western world with its
judeo-christian tradition second is
there indeed a danger of a genuine clash
of civilizations and third is there in
the Europe particularly a loss of faith
in its tradition which makes it
exceptionally vulnerable thank you I
read your column four years I hope you
continue that's Latin well I think there
isn't I can't I'll just talk about the
third one I mean I think that there is a
sense of loss of faith in in Europe if
what the call remains is the
Christian faith I mean you I read and in
the press that there the attendance in
the Catholic churches and both in Italy
and in France are down and that the
Vatican is concerned about the loss of
Christian enthusiasm and dock doctrine
on the part of its European parishioners
and is therefore directing my much of
its effort toward Africa and in Latin
America I can't I don't see the so that
that is true and this of course is the
basis of the feeling I think with
respect to Sarkozy these attitude toward
admitting Turkey into the European Union
the clash of civilization I don't see as
clearly I mean I see the the war in Iraq
being more about Iraq than it is about a
clash of civilisations between Islam and
the United States I mean this it's about
power with with we go back to the
question of distribution of wealth and
power with but it's within the the
Islamic religion I mean it's the quarrel
between Sunni and Shia it is a quarrel
between Iraq and Iran if you can
remember in 1980s it was a prolonged war
between Iran and Iraq and possibly that
this will encompass Saudi Arabia or
Syria but but it's that kind of it's
about local politics more than it is
Clash of Civilizations Spring Island
South Carolina hi hi thank you for
taking my call mr. Levin in general are
you optimistic or pessimistic for the
West and the battle of ideas between it
and Islam and in the long run can we
both endure thank you
the answer is yes we can both indoor and
the the answer is optimistic I mean on
the net we will manage the West will
manage to reinvent itself I mean the
great talent of the West has been its
openness to new idea new technique new
forms of communication and the I was
recently reading a book like this a
current book called by a man named Colin
Murphy called are we Rome which is a
fine fine book which I recommend to thee
but he presents the notion of he
addresses the question is the American
Empire like the Roman Empire about to
decline and fall and his answer to that
is yes and no it in it his point being
that America has reinvented itself more
than once and so as the so as the West I
mean the America that of the 1787 in
Philadelphia no longer exists neither
does the America of Abraham Lincoln nor
does the America into which I was born
in 1935 I mean they I believe one of the
great American Historians Henry Adams
said no American ever dies in the
country in which he was born and that's
true so that we have a chance to
we invent what we mean by America or by
civilization or by globalization and so
in the long run I am optimum history it
gives you the sense that new ideas
appear religions form sort of States so
do families and and over time we salvage
from the wreckage of families or of
Empires the tools which which with which
to build a new future and I think we
will have no choice what else can you do
to our viewers who are interested in the
in what mr. Lapham is reading in who his
favorite authors and favorite books are
in just a few moments we're going to be
showing you a list of his of those
things and so you might want to grab a
pencil piece of paper it's kind of a
long list and so you might want to do
that in order to take down some notes
you have lived you said in New York
since when 1960 and you have how many
children three tell me about him my
oldest son is 34 years old Andrew who is
now living in Toronto and he is himself
the boys at the moment he's the father
of three children under three and he's
about to have a fourth child of the
three as there are twins in the
arrangement and he's in the financial
investment business in in Toronto
married to a Canadian woman
my daughter
the Canadian woman is the daughter of
Brent Mulroney right yes yes Caroline is
that is the daughter of Brian Mulroney
is the former Prime Minister of Canada
my daughter is 31 and she is living in
her name is Delfina and she is living in
Rome there's now the proud mother of a
new baby which he's very happy with
she's married to an Italian Prince and
the my third child Winston is in New
York and he is in the investment
business and he is 25
Winston Delfina where do those know the
names come from paying them your
children actors just like the my wife
like the sound of the names how long
have you been married - married 35 years
so you were you're 72 yeah yeah I'm some
of you were about 37 or so I was 37 when
I got married a little later in life a
little later in life by choice yeah by
choice I mean I buy that time I was
understood what I was I was I was ready
and and and willing and thankful to be
married which is so and I also was I
wanted to be have children
next is New York City hi hello question
short question middle of if you were of
an incredible efforts underhanded - for
collaboration with Israel in a
pre-emptive attack on Iran they would
for the United States interfaith a
complete end tour thank you I'm sorry I
didn't understand that didn't understand
all of it but he was talking about a
pre-emptive war on by Israel on Iran
well I know that's been brooded about
talked about and internet similar to the
Israeli preemptive strike in Iraq some
years ago but all I know is what I've
read in the in the papers I have no
special information was the best
essayist you said you in life you
consider yourself an essayist versus a
journalist or or an intellectual in in
our history Oh in our history well I
would say oh I'm usually going to always
say Mark Twain because I think of him
Twain as the finest were the greatest of
the American writers that I know of and
he wrote in so many different forms I've
read you know he wrote novels he wrote
burlesque he wrote columns for
newspapers sketches and so forth and I
know he's written some essays and I
would I guess I would just on blind
faith and instinct say that about 20 and
it's certainly bernard de voto to me is
we're not I've written this column for
Harper's Magazine
it's been called notebook over the last
thirty years but during an earlier
formulation of Harper's Magazine it was
called the easy-chair and it was written
between 1935 and 1954 by Bernard de voto
and his essays to me are truly
magnificent I mean he's a fine writer he
has a great sense of style in his book
1846 year of decision which is about the
American westward migration is as good a
book of American history as I know
and I'm truly I reread from time to time
and devoted essays and Harper's Magazine
and I think that if I was really good at
it that is what I would try to become
yes I did
no yes they have dead at all I mean the
not only in Harper's Magazine but the
you find it in The New Yorker you find
it in the Atlantic you find a short form
of essay today is the is the op-ed page
piece that is in fact an essay it's it's
much reduced but we live in an age of
digest and reduction anyway so no the
essay form is very much alive and well
Lewis Lapham is our guest this month on
in depth in depth and we are going to
now show you a little bit about where he
works and how he writes where he writes
when he writes and also look the list
that we promised you we'll be back with
more of your calls in just a few moments
my office now is is on Irving place in
New York City it is the office from
which I'm organizing the publication of
a new publication a quarterly Journal
Lapland quarterly which will devote
itself to historical texts of one kind
or another four times a year we will
take one large subject that's more or
less in the news whether it's war or
atheism or division of church and state
or education or the dream of utopia some
topic that is under the headlines and I
will write a brief introduction framing
the past in the presence of present in
the past and then the quarterly will run
out a series of maybe 50 or 60 texts on
that theme from writers in the archive
of Western civilization as well as
writers from you know the Chinese and
Middle Eastern traditions a typical
writing day I come in in the morning my
office 8:39 and then try to write up
until noon and get done however much I
can get done and then use the rest of
the day to read manuscript talk on the
telephone think of further ideas
sometimes when deadlines for let's say
Harper's Magazine is very close I will
then work all day on the on the writing
but I I try to do it for three hours in
the morning I started out when I first
left college a long time ago wanting to
become a historian but I didn't have the
patience
or graduate school became a journalist
and now I have returned to my delight in
history as an editor if you the
excitement is is to essentially say to
the reader look this is a wonderful
singer we'd read this and the you will
take pleasure in it or you will be glad
you did
I mean that's the whole impulse of being
an editor I mean you want to find
something over here that is
extraordinary or exciting or
entertaining what leads to the discovery
of self or one of the riddles of the
universe and then take it from over here
and presented to the reader and say
behold a a child was born I've always
got to it two or three books going at
the same time at the moment I'm reading
the memoirs of William Tecumseh Sherman
reading rereading one of Patrick
O'Brian's novels I'm reading a book a
new book called are we Rome by a man
named Colin Murphy and I'm also reading
a history of Genghis Khan the learning
of something to me is an antidote to
cynicism or despair or you know I mean
it's a if you're feeling lost or
depressed the best way to get around or
over that feeling is by learning
something I think I mean it doesn't
matter whether you're learning music or
whether you're learning chemistry or how
to assemble airplane models or how to
play better golf but but the notion of
learning is an excitement
[Music]
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals this weekend book TV
covers book Expo America in New York
City the publishing industry's largest
annual trade show and next week we'll
cover the Chicago Tribune's 23rd annual
printers row book fair
the two-day free outdoor literary event
is the largest in the Midwest next on
Saturday the 23rd head to Manhattan
Central Park for the New York Book
Festival which hosts book panels
storytelling circles and signings then
July 5th through 7th marked the 4th
anniversary of the Freedom Fest from Las
Vegas also in July the Tokyo
International Book Fair Asia's leading
publishing tradeshow
then in September Burnsville hosts the
Carolina mountains literary festival
which includes writing and publishing
workshops also in September go to
Vermont's largest city for the third
annual Burlington Book Festival and
later that month it's the National Book
Festival in Washington DC
sponsored by the Library of Congress and
first lady Laura Bush please let us know
about book fairs and festivals in your
area and we'll add them to our list
email us at book TV at c-span org here
are the ten best-selling hardcover
nonfiction books from the New York Times
the listen select sales for the week
ending May 19th first on the list God is
not great if Christopher Hitchens
argument that religion is man-made and
murderous then Walter Isaacson with his
new biography Einstein Barbara
Kingsolver follows with Animal Vegetable
miracle which recounts our families year
eating only homegrown and local food
debuting in the fourth spot
Plato and a platypus walk into a bar
Thomas Cathcart and Daniel Klein take a
humorous look at the various schools of
philosophy Ishmael bayad describes his
drug craze killing spree as a child
soldier in Sierra Leone in a long way
gone it's v next pope benedict xvi
explores the identity of jesus centered
the gospels present
courage moves up to number seven Michael
Beschloss profiles nine presidents that
he says were brave enough to make
unpopular decisions George tennis memoir
at the center of the storm is eighth the
former CIA director says he warned the
Bush administration about Al Qaeda prior
to 9/11 then where of all the leaders
gone
former Chrysler CEO Lee Iacocca on
American leadership and rounding out the
top ten is John Feinstein fails from
q-school his look at the PGA Tour's
qualifying tournament where golfers vie
for a spot on the Pro Tour to view the
complete list visit the New York Times
website at nytimes.com and click on
books
we're back with in-depth with Lewis
Lapham you were quoted iris Khanna in a
piece last year saying that cigarettes
are life itself I still smoke honey
that's your question I mean I know it's
unhealthy on the other hand when he
stacked I guess I started when I was in
college and though I gave it up once for
about three months and then decided it
was such a pleasure that I returned and
you take a lot of heat for it
increasingly yes I mean sure I mean
there was up until about ten years ago
it was considered perfectly standard as
it was in the movies and I mean I now
understand it in the movies if somebody
is seen smoking the movie has to be rep
you know rated X what do you think about
that oh I think it's uh I think it's an
exaggerated response I mean I I don't
think secondhand smoke is that damaging
the also in terms of whether or not one
will contract cancer or heart disease is
that I don't I don't think that there is
a necessarily clear connection
clearly it is smoking is not as healthy
as it might be but the I don't think it
is that presents the general population
with as much risk as some of the
anti-smoking people would suggest you
we've been talking about quite heavy
issues of war and issues of the
government but you also have written
some lighter books I've written lighter
books and many of the essays and the
that the recent ones also have a good
deal of humor in them yeah and what what
about the writing with humor why is that
important to you and and is it difficult
is it difficult for a writer to find
that middle place to talk about
something as serious as Lord foreign
policy and still use some humor well it
is difficult in this country it is not
so difficult in England or in France the
there's a fine book currently out by a
man named Clive James called cultural
amnesia and a new collection of his
essays and the reflections on numbers of
important people in the 20th century
it's a fine piece of work and he makes
that point that in in the u.s. we are we
tend to be suspicious of a writer who
uses both humor and and to make a
serious point this of course was also a
problem for Twain to some degree because
Twain
has a truly marvelous sense of humor and
it becomes more acerbic as he as he
becomes older but he keeps it away from
his persona as the light-hearted man in
the white suit from from the West and
Will Rogers could do it many of the
writers in the 20s and the 30s EB what
EB white writes was a with a great deal
of humor so does James Thurber but and
they are addressing serious topics but
again after World War two we begin to
take ourselves seriously with we as the
Americans didn't take ourselves quite so
seriously before we became masters of
the universe and the supreme military
and economic power after World War two
and also the with the construction and
demonstration of the atomic bomb we now
hold in our hands the powers that once
we're assigned to God and so you begin
to get a separation in the u.s. there
are the serious subjects or there are
the light subjects and and then never
the twain shall meet so that you could
go to a bookstore and find under the
catalogue I mean under the sign humor
you can find both Voltaire and Garfield
the cat Voltaire wrote with a great deal
of humor so to Denis Diderot so did
Franklin by the way if you read
Franklin's letters you find that they
are filled with a a it's not stand-up
comedy but it is is
approach to the world his sense his
tolerance his sense of understanding is
very much informed by a sense of humor
and I think that that is what gives
perspective so that you know even though
I am writing essays that take a somewhat
bleak view of American politics I'm not
suggesting that this is the end of the
world because again that's what the
study of history provides it instills a
sense of humor
I'm certainly yeah well it makes you
understand that the other people have
been confronted with similar don't want
us and that it makes you less harsh on
your own generation 2003 put out 30
satires I did you know with the blurb
from Lisa Simpson on the front that's
true I have a picture of Lewis Lapham on
my binder Simpson this time since that's
right buddy that appeared in one of the
episodes of The Simpsons so that over
the course of time I mean I some months
I write an essay that that you know
takes a fairly high tone and other once
I write in a more like light-hearted
vein and earlier in 1999 you wrote
Lampoon's rules of influence what did
you what were you trying to do here I
was writing a satirical self-help book
how to conduct oneself in a society to
achieve self advancement and success and
so on and these kinds of books of
etiquette were common in the 18th
century Washington writes one and of
course so does Franklin in his that's
part of the composition of his poor
Richard series for example first
impressions you write the first
impression is always the last impression
which is why it's always important to
wear clean shoes you don't wish to be
remembered as the stain on the rug
that is true and but you go through here
everything from grant proposals to
insolence to on being seen to the best
people which under which you write you
recognize them by their clothes not
their character well that is true may
you if you read the celebrity pages or
if you read the society pages you you
would you wouldn't be far wrong growing
that conclusion people comment on your
dress as being that you dress
meticulously that you would dress very
well is that something that you just
just that you enjoy doing or is that
something you've cultivated no that's
just something I got in the habit of
doing when I was going to I still come
out of the in the 50s when I go to
school and college it was still a fairly
formal one always had to wear a coat and
tie the I can remember in New York in
the 50s that a woman wouldn't think of
going into the streets without wearing a
dress and in some instances without
wearing gloves and men were wearing
suits and I can even remember where they
were still wearing hats the again you
can see it if you look in the if you
look at the films that are made in the
40s 30s you can see that and I learned
that as a young man and I never gave up
the practice you mentioned earlier that
you've written for television right tell
us about your documentary that you wrote
I wrote well which one I read two of
them the one you wrote on class in the
one I wrote well that's the more recent
one I wrote one in 1989 on the history
of American foreign policy in the 20th
century I made that one for in England
British channel for it was a six-part
series
the second one is called the American
ruling class which I made two three two
years ago it was at the Tribeca Film
Festival even and that is a that comes
out of the book on Lapham's rules of
influence and it is hard documentary and
part musical part dramatic fiction it's
a combination of it's a hybrid form
which was a great deal of fun to make
and I start with the premise that I have
two graduates of Yale University and so
the film starts in a quadrangle Yale
University on a graduation day and here
are these two students they were not in
fact Yale students when one was an
intern at Harvard magazine and the other
was a relative of the producer but they
were both the right age they and they
had a they could play themselves in
other words they were not professional
actors and the premise is that okay you
graduated from Yale and to to what
purpose
why have your parents sent you here and
paid $40,000 a year whatever it cost per
yield graduate of graduate again it
could have been Harvard it could have
been Duke it could have been Stanford
and again we go back to the point of the
American elite it's to become part of
the elite is to open the path toward
wealth power and influence whether in
the corporate world or the financial
world of the political world the
State Department the make to become a
maker of America's culture so you take
them around and introduce it I take them
around I mean they say that I say listen
you're you you have a chance now to
become members of the American ruling
class and they say well there is no such
thing as a ruling class in America this
isn't I think you know this is an
egalitarian society and I said well yes
and no I mean it has a more porous
opening to the higher echelon but there
still is a a ruling class and if you
give either of you gentlemen decide you
want to make an inspection call me up
and so they come to New York and I give
them the Grand Tour I have a clip of it
let's show our viewers where you can
respond to it Jack this is a great venue
to ask about the American ruling class
and while you're here tonight Jack there
are certain rules that would be useful
for you to remember first seek out the
acquaintance of people richer and more
important than yourself and don't take
an interest people who can't do you any
favors when you yourself become rich and
famous then you can collect friends in
the same way that nineteen collects
prize athletes for the full of the
second of Spain once collected for
annually by a president can you really
buy the President of the United States
where were you educated knew a and so
what do you what do you recommend that a
young man setting out in the world in
America do today what are the options
well if you could make humanity proud of
you instead of a shame
by doing what by doing something
virtuous and the Christian descriptions
of virtuous behavior and how that oh not
so good
we're even trying to discover if in fact
there is an American ruling class I'm
afraid there is I don't think it served
democracy well as
I think it is the ruling grass is the
rich who really command our industry our
commerce our finance and those people
are able to so manipulates our our
democracy that they really control the
motors I feel and that's the way it
really is Monday August
is
[Music]
100 should he try to enjoin it
by all means
more sensitive to our democratic needs
join the ruling class more successful
our democracy will be and more likely
its survival
so did you script all this or was this
just something that you kind of did on
the slide with and what some of a
scripted within the scene that you just
saw that takes place at the 50th
anniversary of the Paris Review
it was just after George Plimpton who
was the editor of The Paris Review that
had died and but there was still this
enormous what they call revel in Jeffrey
on a in New York on 42nd Street was that
it was a handsome celebration and the
elite of New York of various from
various strata I mean you saw there was
water Cronkite but it was also Kurt
Vonnegut who was also Charlie Rhodes and
was also Peter Matheson and and here was
a an opportunity to introduce one of the
young men in the in the film to what I
was talking about and but it is
completely unscripted
in other words high water chronic I'd
had no idea that I was going to be there
and what he says about the American
ruling class is right off the top of his
head I mean without a note without prior
thought and the same thing is true upon
I get in the same thing is true all the
way through the film I mean I write the
the voiceovers and a lot of the
connective tissue to get from one scene
to another but then when I managed to
bring the young man into the presence of
among others James Baker Larry Summers
who was then president of Harvard or
Bill Bradley or Pete Peterson it is
entirely or Arthur salzburger actually
appears in one scene to the publisher of
the New York Times
and it is because it is the the young
man asking the question the people
answering the question are not
suspicious of betrayal at the heads of
the liberal news media so they so they
they answer the questions very
straightforwardly and that's what gives
the film its strength to get back to
small phone calls
Lewis Lapham is our guest and he is our
guest this month on in depth we are live
from New York City we take our first
call from Cape Cod hello hello good
afternoon it's a delight to see you and
to hear mr. Lapham mr. laughing with the
Impala tick for me to ask you a question
actually about the magazine no good I
don't think any place except about that
I've been reading it for at least 15
years and I missed the art on the cover
hello who in the magazine or was that
your decision to put those beautiful
pieces of artwork on the cover yes I
mean well well in part my my together
with the with the art director but that
is not one you're not referring to that
this is would be the newer one new a
picture of the my June 2007 issue with
George Bush on the cover with a cowboy
hat on no I appreciate that that's going
to sell some magazines but I miss the
artwork well the artwork is still there
from from time to time I think a couple
of months ago you would have seen a
cover of William Shakespeare I believe
they did a they did a lead piece on
Shakespeare and you I think you would
have seen a painting but it I had more
preference for painting than I did for a
photograph more in the sense of
illustration and then they in a sense to
sell a magazine but again that's a
matter of taste and I think you will
find that there will be more paintings
on the cover from
time what about Lapham quarterly what
happens quarterly was just a new
historical journal that I'm beginning to
put together we'll have both painting
and photography next Naples Florida
hello hello I am interested in the
education in grammar he talked about
because I too thought I got a lot out of
my grammar teachers and through the
years the schools have had no writing
for our kids generation and now they're
letting the kids write all the time but
they had left them spell anyway they
sound and and not worry about grammar or
punctuation or anything I would like him
to comment on that or if he thinks any
kind of writing is better than no
writing and my other question is all the
biographies recently of the founding
fathers and founding mothers and even
though they had their egotist and their
infighting they still magnificent
statesmen and gave so much to the
country and I wondered if he thinks
there's any hope for the future and
finding men like that and women like
that no it's weapons I think there is a
hope but I think that the it's can and I
think it's connected to language the the
the early founding fathers are all of
them
historians I mean they're all they read
I mean and they write well and democracy
is about really really reading and
writing because it's so the ideas can
get quite complicated and so can the
arguments and it's about being able to
express one's thought either in speeches
or on paper and you find that we have
that talent to an extraordinary degree
when you need to think of the not only
the writing of Benjamin Franklin with
the writing of Abraham Lincoln or the
writing of Teddy Roosevelt the and it
continues throughout the all of the 19th
and
much of the 20th century and that I have
we published in Harper's Magazine some
years ago the examination paper for the
eighth grade in a small town in Kansas
in 1895 and what they were asking those
students to do the today's seniors at
Harvard I don't think would have been
able to answer even half the questions
this is why the first thing that was
done usually when the Americans were
settling the West was to build a school
it's why Lincoln in the 1860s passes the
land-grant college bill I mean the point
is that democracy only works with an
educated citizenry and the circumstances
have changed since the advent of
television and since the we haven't yet
really found I mean we have the internet
which people can use as a means of
communication at which they become as
fluent as they are talking on a
telephone but it which is good but but
the but it hasn't yet evolved into a
literary form of address or even a form
of address in which we can truly invent
a new political dispensation I mean when
I was asked by an earlier caller about
the hope of the civilization of the West
but before the there can be a revival or
a restoration or a triumph or a new
beginning however you want to address
that question it has to first come with
language and how we find that language
out of the material that we now have
which is to the most part electronic and
either internet or television
I think we still involved with the
discovery of a new technology that we
haven't yet made that technology into a
as expressive of form as we might hope
either from a literary point of view or
from a political point of view three
vlogs TV blogs I don't know what forms
it will take thee I highly influenced in
my thought on this subject by Marshall
McLuhan who wrote a book in 1964 called
understanding media and he begins with
the premise that we shape our tools and
then our tools shape us and at the end
of the 15th century comes Gutenberg with
his printing press and for a while it's
but it's another hundred years before
you get to Shakespeare in 110 and
Cervantes and there's a great deal of
objection to to the printing press by
the then established scholarly class
which are for the most part church
people been dealing in illuminated
manuscripts and want to have a monopoly
on the means of communication it gets
out of their hands and now the internet
is out of the hands of the schools and
so I don't know who teaches grammar in
the way that I was taught grammar but
it's almost as if we have to find a new
a new language go to Georgia next elope
yes oh good afternoon I wanted to ask if
you're familiar with and your opinion on
a book by Arnold Toynbee in 1947
civilization on trial in which he owned
up
warns about the rapid spread of Western
civilization awakening on what he termed
the slumbering of Neolithic populations
of the world and what that would entail
for advanced civilizations any knowledge
of that I can remember having read that
but I read it so long ago that I don't
have the frame of the argument clearly
in mind but a number of other people
have made the same points I mean I've
read drunk barson on on the same subject
I read Oswald Spengler on the same
subject
I read George Orwell on the same subject
many people from many different points
of view have remarked upon the
deterioration of what they would call
civilization but then you have to bear
in mind that the civilization that in
most instances are talking about is is a
civilization of the elites
I mean it's based on an elite premise by
the few of the few and for the few and
when you base it much broadly much more
broadly on a democratic basis certain
kinds of standards get lowered but again
this is the problem that we face which
is to find the language to make a
civilization with the new tools that we
now have at hand
Averell Massachusetts yes thanks Katya
the salaat man there's an awful lot of
angry Democrats out here who I really
disgusted with the Democrats because of
the district for instance their recent
vote on the Iraq war caving and Jeb Bush
and also we have one instrument an ass
the impeachment and conviction of a
president to removal from office in the
Senate and the very first words come out
of speaker Pelosi's mouth was a vo-tech
selection was impeachment off the table
while she's sending Bush a signal don't
worry nothing's going to happen to you
we're not going to investigate you this
even before they had in any implica
hearings you're almost like hearings on
the House Judiciary or the Senate
committee so in other words what
president will ever be impeached if the
process of impeachment against any
president for doing high crimes mr.
Deane misdemeanors no well I don't know
if you were listening the early part of
the program but Connie earlier read
passage from a column that I wrote it at
the time that Pelosi made that statement
on coming to Washington and saying that
impeachment was off the table which I
thought the point of the column was that
was a mistake
because if you if this wasn't the time
to impeach a president and there never
was going to be a time and and the the
again a trend over the last not just the
Bush administration but beginning since
World War two has to been to Center more
and more power in the hands of the
executive to override the doctrine of
separation of powers may not Congress
hasn't declared a war since World War
two under the so I think and given the
again a subject we've been talking about
the distribution of wealth and power and
placing more of it in the hands of the
executive takes it away from the Senate
it's the Senate's constitutional duty as
I understand it to impeach bush I mean
not for personal reason to it because
the man is clearly harmed the American
body politic I mean to remove bushes it
is comparable to removing a tumor from a
an organism the organism being
the Commonwealth of the United States
but there is I again given the given a
flow of events toward an increasing
concentrations of power and in an
executive branch of government the
chances become more and more remote
presidential candidates you wrote last
year of Hillary Clinton I don't have any
respect or regard or hope for Hillary do
you still feel that way well I don't you
know I think I probably change that
attitude I mean I I can't where did I
stand uh sorry I don't think I wrote
that you did not write it you were
quoted in an article in the progressive
that was written by Ruth Connick it was
a quote that she had you saying I don't
remember writing that because that I
would signed a little too peremptory and
I don't usually yeah my apology it was a
quote from you according to her article
well I may have said something like that
but I I think you have to respect
Hillary Clinton for her knowledge
concern civic mindedness
willingness to undertake the life of
politics she's a very bright woman but I
don't think that her thinking is in any
way new I I can't expect her I don't
expect her to come up with anything
other than a revision of this she's very
much part of the status quo a part of
the system I mean there's nothing
revolutionary in her approach I mean and
what I hear from the various critics not
only of the both on the Democratic and
on the Republican side is the the wish
for some form of new thinking or some
somebody who would say something clearly
and effectively and that would give a
hope for the future I don't think at
least I haven't heard that from any of
the candidates this this time I was
thinking of John Edwards and his
thoughts of maybe not specifically
ruling class but haves and have-nots
does that mesh with what your that mess
is in part yeah I mean the but again I
haven't paid enough at least this early
in the campaign to what Edwards is
saying but the till we say okay we are
in this place and this is what we are
trying to accomplish these are what is
what politics is about politics is not
about saving souls it's about making a
common infrastructure which includes
social justice as well as the building
of roads and the setting up of such
bodies as the Securities and Exchange
Commission and the Coast Guard and
clearly defining what it is that
politics can and cannot do and certainly
I would think health insurance would be
part of that education would be part of
that the greatest resource that the
country has are its people and anything
that you can do to strengthen that
resource which would be health
environment education to me does a great
deal more to preserve enhance the
national security than the investment in
military adventure Franklin Tennessee hi
hi I just wanted to make the observation
that I do think there is a ruling elite
in this country it is Jewish
it is very wealthy and it is a very
left-wing indeed 126 of the Forbes 400
are Jews and there are only 2% of the
population of the US and they control
about 22 percent of the wealth welcome
any reaction I I would disagree with
that I mean I realized that there are
many very wealthy Jews and that they
control that those individuals or groups
of individuals control large
corporations some of them in the in the
news media but I would not say that the
American ruling elite is Jewish by any
measure of the if you look at the
corporate world if you look at the maybe
not the individual wealthiest but if you
look at the structure of American
corporations American law firms the
lobbyists in Washington the people that
are around President Bush the people who
contribute large sums of money to the
Republican Party the so-called Rangers
and the pioneers and so on I would think
you would find that it was a a
multicultural collection of wealth
wealth is be a common denominator but I
just think it is more diverse social
Pennsylvania hello hello I have two
questions what do you think about the
emergence of black order the
paramilitary mercenary force and its
threat to democracy since it's subject
to no constitutional restraint and the
fact that throughout history despotic
movements
have relied on private mercenary forces
and also picking up on the title of your
latest book pretensions of empire
wouldn't you agree that this is a
continuation of manifest destiny the
doctrine that our country has the
god-given right to do whatever we please
starting with taking over this land from
the Native Americans and it's just
continuing throughout the world thanks
coach Ville mr. Lapham well us both
those questions are a very interesting
ones the as I understand the I'll take a
second one first the Americans I think
conceived of their Empire as the
continental United States much of the
movement West is is done by aggregations
of private individuals moving moving
west and as in terms of almost randoms
settlement I mean is not done with by
the United States cavalry I mean the
cavalry figures in the story but it
we're not talking about the Roman
legions and and you also have many
people in the United States among them
as I said earlier Thoreau and Lincoln
who are objecting to the notion of war
with Mexico as far as overseas Empire is
concerned that the Western settlement is
is a notion of clearing a frontier
wilderness and
most of the Native Americans certainly
in the east in the way London are are
destroyed by disease very early on
rather than by with weapons well I think
early forms of smallpox and typhoid
typhus kill something like 80% of the
Indian population in an eastern seaboard
you can make that argument about
westward the course of Empire which of
course is the big painting in Capitol
Hill in Washington in the in the Capitol
building overseas I'm quite a different
question and I think that we become an
empire you can argue that both ways
though the Mexican sorry the
spanish-american war is an elective war
in which the imperial interest in the
East very clearly which is to take over
Cuba and the Philippines and make
America a great imperial power this is
what Twain is constantly argue it's an
argument on the other point the
outsourcing of the American military in
putting our military forces more and
more in the hands of private interests
is a ominous trend I think I mean the
Romans find themselves doing this
relying after the Republic which where
the military is consists of the to a
large extent the citizenry both the the
peasant farmer and the the more opulent
upper-class who young men must learn to
go to war and that's the way they
achieve political office and that part
of the of the Republic as the Empire
begins to decay more and more of the
military function is assigned to
mercenaries what are their Visigoths
sore vandals or Syrians some people
imported into the Empire to do the to do
the heavy lifting and the armies become
private I mean you have Caesar raising
his own army and so does Pompey and so
does Crassus and then it's who compared
who could pay for the soldiery I think I
don't know the number but we now have in
Iraq I think that they give the number
for the American military as a hundred
and thirty thousand I think that's right
but there is another at least fifty
thousand maybe more than that of private
contractors more and more of our
militaries is being outsourced as are
more and more of our government
functions I mean there are now more
private law enforcement officers I mean
lord fort not officers but security
guards there's more private law
enforcement in the United States and
there is public and we're giving we're
privatizing the prisons and in some
cases are our Border Patrol so and if
the history of you know of the Roman
Empire is of any has any analogy you can
see that once he once a government
begins to privatize itself it has less
and less chance of serving as a
Democratic Republic it becomes the
creature of demagogue or wealth or some
form of private interests Cleveland
hello your next time I three questions
all related to one subject what do you
feel is that can you elaborate on the
connection between the Bush
in the oil industry and then the
connection between oil and the war in
Iraq and third why doesn't the
mainstream media spend any time on the
subject thank you well I see a very
direct connection between the Bush
family in the oil industry I mean not
only in Houston but also in Saudi Arabia
and I would think that the oil was was
if not the primary motive for our
invasion certainly one of two or three
primary concerns I mean in in the book
written by secretary Paul O'Neill who
was briefly the Secretary of the
Treasury
appointed by Bush honey he comes into
office and as early as 2001 Bush has
just taken office given his first
inaugural speech and soon thereafter
O'Neill attends his first cabinet
meeting and is astounded to find people
talking about the possible invasion of
Iraq and also their spread out on the
table are maps of all the oil fields in
in Iraq and and who has got interests in
what and and you know and have the
French kind of interest in this or the
Germans in that and but anything as you
can see the the American government our
coalition made it a condition on the
setting up of the Iraqi Constitution
that the control of the Iraqi oil
resources be placed in the hands of
foreign owners consortiums whether an
American and and and or European so and
again to make another point for the
we probably drive the nail unnecessarily
into the point but several years ago I
can't remember what year I was at the
Virginia Military Institute and I
believe Lexington Virginia
TMI TMI yeah anyways VMI yeah and I was
there for two day conference discussing
American military strategy and foreign
strategy and I can remember briefing by
a colonel in the US Army who we're in a
seminar room and and he puts up a great
big map of the Central Asia map that
included who's Becca Stan Kazakh Stan
Afghanistan the Pakistan and he he just
drew a big circle around the that all of
those countries and he said for our
purposes we can just think of all of
this as pipeline of Stan so yesterday
the short answer your question is
clearly the control of the Middle
Eastern oil resource the Iraq s-- was
among the chief reasons for our going to
war queens your next time
ah yes a buy on the air yes you are sir
ah Connie thank you for c-span I'm a big
fan and missile laughing ah I'm a buyer
of your work although I don't agree with
you 100 percent of times in the immortal
words of Ronald Reagan I rather have an
80% friend than 20% enemy
I said I'll make a quick gamma a
lifelong Republican I voted for George W
Bush twice in 2004 my question is I was
also a big fan of Cheney when he was in
the
the Bush administration is lifelong work
of government I thought he had the
experience of know how and when our
current President George W Bush was
elected he set up his cabinet around the
old hands the so-called old hands Colin
Powell Cheney and Rumsfeld my question
to you is I'm hanging on my fingernails
my frustration ah with this
administration what changes it I'd like
your opinion what changes of it that our
current president would not tap into the
enormous our knowledge and experience of
his dad I'm 42 years old I asked my dad
for his opinion my dad is 75 years old
from the smallest to the largest issues
I would rather they come out and say hey
we wanted to Iraq to get rid of a bad
guy was climbing WMDs and plus we need
oil so we find a more resource are on a
hundred resource we need access to the
oil we're a great country without oil we
come to a standstill I would be okay
Wayne Thanks Thank You clean well I
think a lot of people would be ok with
that with it with the with the with the
caller's point if the if it was put that
clearly I think up great many people in
the United States would understand that
and and you can then say this is the
kind of country we are we are not this
we're not necessarily everybody's friend
but in order to remain the most powerful
country in the world which we think is
for a benign and good purpose we need
oil I mean is that argument could have
been made and could be persuasive and
there are people
willing to make it and possibly among
them the the first George Bush I take
his point and I can understand his
frustration I mean and this is one of
the problems that we are having both on
the Republican and on a democratic side
of our political argument as to what is
it that what is our objective what what
do we really what are the words mean and
if somebody can you know explain that to
me clearly and honestly I think that
that person would have a good chance I'm
going to go back up to a journalism
question um or your career question
which is that it's been about I think
about three years now since you came
under some criticism for piece you wrote
tentacles of rage in which in which
inside it you you mentioned what was
going on at the Republican convention
when in fact it hadn't happened yet
you took some heat for that was it was
it fair no I don't think it was fair I
think it was the a misunderstanding on
the part of the people who got excited
about that what in fact I was doing well
but what I it was one sentence and I was
writing in July for an issue that was
going to appear in September mm-hmm so I
was writing as if the that the September
date line was on what was current and
I've done this before with with columns
she were writing about what you what was
what was being said at the Rio when I
was mentioned but I didn't know I didn't
quote anything and to say I simply said
that the the the kind of rhetoric that
would be that was coming out of the
convention
now which was true I mean it turned out
to be exactly as I had predicted it
would be because it was such a you know
it was a part of the political decor I
mean you would describe just his way you
would say the balloons were in the air
because you knew the balloons were going
to be in the air and you would say that
the rhetoric was in the air because you
knew it would be and it's so I didn't I
didn't think very much of it but the but
some people got upset and I well I think
I explained yeah yeah our viewers
example Jack Schaeffer in Slate said
every overtax journalist phones in from
time to time if you dare to make the
call from a parallel universe as Lapham
did and then step forward to rationalize
it this moxie runs through the whole
essay and in all too often informs whole
issues of Harper's which has grown
increasingly pompous and predictable in
recent years well I mean that is that's
an attack on the the substance of the
article that did not run all the way
through the article but Shafer objected
to the premise of the article which was
that the there is a large the making of
the Republican message machine which has
been taking place over the last twenty
years which involves the bankrolling of
the intellectual policy right by
organizations like Heritage and American
Enterprise and Weekly Standard and
Murdoch and so on so it's the shifting
of ideas toward the right which has been
going on really since the middle 70s but
becomes a flood during the Reagan
administration are you saying that
there's an increase of this or yes there
are also there are also organizations on
the left that fund but they're nowhere
near
as effective or as good at it as the
they keep saying that they know they've
been this why can't we on the left set
up think tanks as effective as the
American Enterprise Institute or
heritage or any number of others and
there they haven't been able to do so
because the Republican right although it
has different elements to it I mean
there's a difference between the you
know the Cato Institute and between the
American enterprise or between some of
the policy Institute's they have and
also but the religious element but they
can get together and act in a concerted
way in order to promote a Republican
agenda that everybody will more or less
recognize them and work with and the
left has never been able to do that I
mean they they tend to argue with each
other and and now this of course this is
what the papers have been talking about
for the last few weeks about the
crumbling of the Republican Alliance and
the factionalism beginning to show
around the issue of immigration as well
as around the issue of Iraq and so but I
mean Shaffer was was disagreeing with
the premise of the essay and used to be
that the sleight-of-hand at the
beginning to discredit the entire essay
which is that is
that is a customary form of criticism
but but I think that's what it was
Boise Idaho hi hello it's a pleasure to
speak with you today mr. Lapham I was
wondering if you could speak to the
dangers this president's usurpation of
power with his signing statements
executive orders and talk about the
entire doctrine of the I believe it's
called the unitary executive what that
may mean for for any future presidential
power and what if anything that can be
done to reverse this precedent thanks
Boise 11i I addressed some of that into
a previous caller just a few seconds ago
there is and I said that there has been
his trend toward the centralization of
power over the last 20 odd years and
that impulse is always present I mean
all it was present in in the Kennedy
administration and if you remember
Arthur Schlessinger I believe wrote a
book called the imperial presidency and
the senator fulbright wrote a book
called the arrogance of power I mean you
can find this impulse whether you're
talking about the administration of
Franklin D Roosevelt or John Kennedy or
or Richard Nixon but it has become more
pronounced over the last 20 years in
association with the shift of the
American political argument toward the
right where the emphasis has been less
on freedom of expression and more on law
and order and and a rising tide of fear
and paranoia than the United States is
under attack from enemies at all points
of the not only the geopolitical compass
but also the moral
compas which was the substance of the
culture wars in the 1980s and 90s and so
the move toward the centralization of
power is defensive it's I think it's
based on a certain fearfulness and the
wish to build impregnable ziggurats and
bureaucracies of such size and
magnificence is to be invincible and the
I think is it's it's a it's a it's a
it's dangerous because it tends to be
based on fear and and gets in the way of
trying to find a a as some of the other
callers have discussed a new a new form
of let's say Western civilization or
democracy or the you know the getting to
the resource of the intelligence and
imagination of the American people and
the so it's bad news because it it's a
sign of retreat and it the only way to
correct it is to elect more people to
the Senate to the to the legislative
side who will take seriously the
doctrine of separation of powers and and
and try to enforce live up to the their
constitutional obligation to exercise
the power of the legislature I don't
think the hope is going to come from the
Supreme Court because the Supreme Court
seems to me to be tending in the same
direction
as the White House and that's no
accident I mean toward the Contras
concentration and centralization of
power every month the first Sunday of
every month we invite an author who has
a large body of work to come and sit
with us and take your phone calls and
talk about the talk about their writing
Lewis Lapham has 13 books what's your
next one gave you discipline I don't I
don't have next one you don't have an
extra one that's not yet is that good or
is it meant for the time being because
I'm concentrating on on doing the lap
ins quarterly Journal and once I get
that set up I'll write another book I
may write a book about the I don't yet
know we'll take a call from Peoria hello
hi I think many moderate liberals and
anti-war activist are being fooled by
the so-called benchmarks be included in
the latest funding legislation well the
key benchmarks is to get Iraq to
privatize its oil and the current
privatization laws written by American
law consultants it forces the national
Iraq oil company to only have 1718 oil
fields Manor 2/3 of a known oil fields
and all yet undiscovered ones we got
programs by private oil companies of
world without probably mean United
States firms no other nations new lease
is privatized its oil so in Arabia
Kuwait bearing in Iran only limited
usage contracts to special oil companies
for two years but the twelve billion
dollar support the troops legislation
passed by Congress requires Iraq in
order to get reconstruction funds for
the United States to privatize oil
resources and put them up for long term
twenty to thirty year contracts so where
the these things sounds benign that
alter our our we have these benchmarks
there's terrific liberals and moderates
and inspire to abuse
into this thing and actually forcing
them to divest themselves well and
what's the United States abscond with
the oil in fact its disguised and you
are exposed in these here magazine your
column I hope you dig into this and
expose these phony big rocks thanks
color any thoughts you know he's right
and I would hope and I think that we
have a article already in hand for
Harper's Magazine coming out and saying
this but I I agree with a minute as I
gave an answer to a prior called core
about the oil interest and my point was
that that we had imposed on them or
required Iraq to write a constitution
giving up its oil to foreign interest
and I don't think they'll agree to that
okay so so the benchmark is completely
fanciful okay Georgia Thank You Connie
great show mr. Laughlin I'm a very
strong and enthusiastic supporter of
governor Mitt Romney for president and
it looks to me like with all the
billions of dollars of pork barrel
spending and government waste it would
be important to have somebody like Mitt
Romney a highly successful businessman
to manage the government and do
something about all the fraud waste and
abuse and I like to have your thoughts
on that thank you very very much well I
don't know anything
obsess about Romney I mean I again from
my point of view we're still very early
in the election cycle so I haven't
really I'm not fully prepared with
Romney's positions are acquainted with
his record but the but sure I mean at
anything that you can do to reduce waste
and corruption is is good whoever can do
that whether that's a businessman or a
former state governor or a politician of
any lawyer I mean but but those purpose
that I'm objective is
admirable it no matter who's and have
you ever voted for a Republican yeah I
voted for Eisenhower I voted for Bush so
in the first the first George Bush
election
yeah and I'm certain sorry for this the
son George Bush won over the father
father
next is Van Nuys California oh go ahead
then I uh I miss Robin what I did when I
don't understand for someone that's
lived I'm 68 years seventy-two is that
every war in this last half century will
actually throughout our entire issues
been based on lies Lincoln Lincoln was a
attempted with the spot resolutions to
stop the mexican-american war which was
based on a lie about where our blood was
shed mark twain you and was not elected
because he was unpatriotic mark twain
tried to was an anti-imperialist member
the anti-imperialist league and rode
great stuff on what happened William
Randolph Hearst managed to overcome
everything with his phony pictures about
the Maine we had that war now this war
the Iraq Wars been going on for 17 years
which nobody seems to acknowledge the
Gulf War we killed 200,000 Iraqis were
retreating after war was over the
sanctions 1991 to 2003 1,500,000 died
25% of them children mostly from a lack
of medicine that would have cured
diarrhea from the tainted water and now
the Iraqi Freedom which no one seems to
mention The Lancet Journal anymore they
don't seem too willing to accept the
most valuable thing that's been analyzed
by this world war at least 600 for a few
thousand have been killed that puts us
over two million equal to the Korean the
Vietnam or Cambodia Leo's uh we are a
warrior society and the people that are
most responsible of the soldiers why do
we honor the troops in this wars my big
question when in Vietnam we made them
ashamed if nine out of ten people killed
in war now civilians
why do we honor troops who are killing
women and babies mr. Nasser well he
raises a number of questions which are
which are good yeah most wars are
founded on lies I mean I think you would
find that true over the course of the
last 2,000 years if you find that true
more often than not certainly the well I
don't think well I don't have certainly
World War our participation in World War
one was was based on a great deal of
false reporting on the part of the
American media and I'm part of the
American government as to what was at
stake in the war between Germany and on
the other side Britain and France
there's a lot of deception on the part
of the Wilson administration there is
some deception to get us into World War
two I mean no I I think it's fairly well
understood that they you know the
Franklin Roosevelt was aware of an
imminent attack on Pearl Harbor but that
we needed something like of that sort in
order to enter the European war on the
British side which I think in retrospect
was a fortunate decision the but it but
but it is generally so that wars are
built on lies well this is last part of
his question I can't remember either he
was building up towards the that whole
point of war and and lies but I'm not
sure exactly what his final point was I
can't remember Tennant I think I agreed
with his forum post his last point but I
I'm sorry it was soldiers the soldiers
were robot into both it's why do we by
disagree with that I don't think we are
a warrior society I think that we that
goes back to the
let's go back to the Revolutionary War
it is very hard for Washington and for
the colonial armies to to raise troops I
mean in order to get militia volunteers
for the Continental Army the government
was having to give give grants of a
hundred and sixty acres of land and the
in the division that there were maybe a
third of the people in the colonies in
the seventeen late 1770s on the side of
the American patriotism a third
indifferent and a third on the Tory side
but it was always a problem with
recruits for us in the Battle of
Yorktown of course is won by the French
I mean and but his question about why we
shouldn't honor people who kill children
I think I see okay I don't I don't know
whether we are honoring people we think
we've always had a tomb of the Tomb of
the Unknown Soldier I believe was
established in 1921 the Memorial Day
idea comes in at the end of the Civil
War Sherman was not hesitant about
killing one of the children in the South
the wars in the 20th century wars
involved more killing women and children
than might then prior I mean there are
more civilians killed during the wars of
the 20th century than our military we
killed a great many women and children
and both in Dresden and it and Hiroshima
and Nagasaki so but I don't think that
again I go back to the point about the
interest of the American democratic
republic and
interest of the American nation state
and the difference between those two
entities the long-standing argument
between them
which you can find as as as early as the
1770s in the US again the civil war the
Lincoln puts out a draft notice for I
don't know how many hundred thousand and
only very few people showed up same
thing through the war of 1812 the the
British are marching on Washington
they're in Maryland Madison puts out a
call for 95,000 American volunteers in
the states of Pennsylvania New Jersey
Maryland of Virginia and five thousand
showed up so I don't think it's a
warrior society I think I think it is
the interest of the warriors of the
nation-state of the would-be Empire to
invent wars but then they always have a
trouble rounding up the boots on the
ground I mean it's been a except in
World War two where we were clearly
attacked by the Japanese and war
declared on us by Hitler three days
later we didn't need a lot of
explanations from Colin Powell as to why
we were at war with Japan and Germany
longtime editor of Harper's has been our
guest for in-depth for the past three
hours he has thirteen books under his
belt you can get a list of them by going
to our website which is book TV org and
you can also go to Lapham z-- quarterly
org to find out more about your new your
new publication which begins when again
October of this year and again the the
premise of it is history it's to frame
the past and the present and the present
in the past and to bring to bear on the
events in the news and the concerns in
the news the the writing of authors who
have proved themselves prescient or wise
so it would it's the great books meant
made topical and in the meantime people
can still read you in Harper's yes how
often every other month six times a year
I wrote a column for Harper's Magazine
thanks for spending the afternoon with
us Thank You Connie for having me
appreciate it very much thanks to our
viewers have a good day